i want to be very clear breathing is not
going to fix
all of your problems right but what i
have found
is that when people have very
dysfunctional breathing when you start
controlling your breathing and you
breathe in a more efficient way
the body can come back into balance
james welcome to the show how crazy has
the last year been for you
after your book came out because it
feels like breath work is everywhere
at the moment well i think it was a
crazy year for everybody for so many
different reasons
i mean you put a pandemic onto a virtual
book tour
onto me finally coming out of my closet
after so many years of research and
writing to be on the other side of the
mic
and it's been uh complete and utter
chaos to put it mildly
but in all almost all good ways so i'm
very grateful for
the attention and i'm very grateful that
people have
discovered breathing as a way to help
improve their health
yeah and you talk about how these
insights of breathing have
been around for a very very long time
you know thousands and thousands of
years
but aren't still now super widely known
isn't it crazy in the 21st century that
we can still have gated information that
there's
stuff that monks and monasteries
somewhere know but that the internet
doesn't
well i think that if you look at
medicine and if you look at so much of
science
this is exactly the pattern it takes is
in one culture a group will discover
something to be true and in another
culture where
that group had no association with the
previous group they discovered the same
exact thing this is true with nutrition
it's true with exercise and it's
certainly true with breathing
so it wasn't that surprising to see that
we've had this huge blind spot
because we've had huge blind spots in
regards to so many other things so many
other
very basic things that have to do with
human health yeah we saw that with
matthew walker's book right
that why we sleep why should a book
about something that everybody does for
a third of their life be so
revolutionary
i was just talking with matthew walker a
couple of weeks ago i was lucky enough
to interview him
uh at a conference our first conference
uh since the pandemic is
somewhat lightened up here in the u.s
and i was
cracking up because when i first heard
of that book i said you have to be
kidding me oh now some guy wants to
teach me how to sleep i sleep just fine
and then we realized that breathing and
sleeping
uh both people expect them to be
a default reaction something that we
don't need to think about
but then you look at populations across
populations of people who are sleeping
people who are breathing dysfunctionally
and there is an epidemic going on on
both of those fronts and there's a lot
of crossover that
that venn diagram between disordered
sleeping
and disordered breathing and so
you know these simple things i think get
so ignored because they're so simple
and yet just adopting the most basic
simple human habits can really enrich
your your life and on so many levels and
the science is very clear about that
yeah very much i think people are
looking for the fancy new pill
or the weird funky workout regime the
contralateral
single arm overhead press with the
kettlebell balanced on one leg like
that's what people are after they don't
want to do deadlifts bench press and
squats
the same with this like what's the new
biohacking tool
that i can use to measure my hrv for
whatever whatever
not you just need to focus on breathing
eating and sleeping correctly
well what i heard from so many
researchers
including my father-in-law was a
pulmonologist and i heard this from
from top-level people at stanford and
harvard
they were all saying the same thing they
said listen there's no way to make money
off of breathing
and that's one of the reasons why this
sounds very cynical but if you think
about it it's true
and it's really hard to make money off
of sleeping uh you can make money off of
sleeping pills but as matthew walker
made very clear
is sleeping pills will put you
unconscious but they won't put you to
sleep all the restorative processes that
happen in sleep are excluded
when you're taking sleeping pills so i
think some of this is commercially
driven
and trust me businesses are going to
find a way of commercializing breathing
they're already finding a way of
commercializing sleeping
in some of those wearables i think are
fantastic by the way
but it i think that now people are much
more empowered to take their health
into their own hands because we've been
so let down by the current systems and
we've really come to this point where
people have been forced to understand
what atp is
and understand how to really lose fat
and understand how to really build
muscle
uh because so much of what we've been
told to eat eat
the wheaties in the morning eat your
cheerios has been just a complete lie
you know what people say a lot they call
it a post-truth world
and it's kind of like that now have you
ever seen the midwit meme
do you know what this is so you have a
guy so it's a meme and on one side you
have this dude that looks a bit like a
neanderthal with the with the brow
and then on the other side you have a
guy that looks like a sage with his hood
up
and then in the middle you have this
sort of screaming internet sort of
entrepreneur and it talks about the the
iq curve
the bell curve and it talks about the
fact that the simple turn and the genius
do the same thing
and you need a particular level of um
intellect in the middle to actually get
confused and get caught up in the weeds
and it kind of seems to be the same here
that you go through this period where
maybe
there's too much information the
information that's out there is trying
to hack the wrong things and then after
a while you just get back to like eat
sleep move breathe like you know
is it do you think it's fair to say this
is something i've been thinking about is
it fair to say that breathing is the
most
sort of direct window into our autonomic
nervous system that we have with without
a doubt
we get most of our energy from
air from our breath people say well how
is that possible
right we get most of our energy from
food and drink
not true if you look at how we make
energy we get most of our energy from
our breath and so if you think that how
you're inhaling 20 000 times a day how
you're exhaling 20 000 times a day
is is not going to make a difference in
your energy levels and how your body
operates
that efficiency of how you get that
energy
you're crazy and you know this stuff is
so simple it's not very sexy to a lot of
people they said well i don't want that
i
i want something that you know i have to
i mean look at what we've done with
nutrition
it's nutrition isn't that complex and
yet for the past 50 years
it's i need this vitamin i need k2
i need my d3 right now i need my fiber
because i don't get enough fiber i need
this mineral because i'm deficient
i mean this is insane or you could just
eat foods that we're designed to eat
and you don't need any of that stuff so
breathing is
is similar in some ways because we're so
removed from the natural
environment hunter-gatherers don't need
breathing re-education right they don't
need sleeping re-education
they don't need nutritional re-education
they are already doing that because
they're in a natural environment and
the further we get away from a natural
environment
environment the more patches we need to
just keep our bodies sustaining
and we've gotten so far into an
industrialized modern living environment
that we've had to reacquaint ourselves
with the most simple things
movement breathing sleep and you can see
what a difference these things
make to your life and overall wellness
it's really weird isn't it because we
can't i can't make myself digest
any quicker or any slower i can't make
my pancreas secrete
things if i want more is there anything
else i was trying to think is there
anything else
that we can actually impact with regards
to the sort of rest and digest system
other than our breathing
so you're you're right we can't take
control of our kidney function
right just with your brain you can't
take control of your
your the amount that your heart is
beating right per minute
but when you breathe in certain ways you
can control
and influence all of these different
functions
and even our organs you can actually
influence how you're digesting food you
can influence your kidney function
you can influence your liver function
you can influence your heart rate if you
don't believe me
take an inhale to account about three
and then take a very long exhale to
count about eight do that a few times
and feel how your heart rate lowers
right your blood pressure is going to
likely go down as well
this is magical voodoo stuff no one
would believe that we would have
the ability to control this the
autonomic nervous system is called
autonomic as in
automatic beyond our control
and yet we can immediately
affect it and influence it by impacting
and controlling our breathing and what's
so great about this is you don't have to
take
subjective markers you can measure what
happens
within a few seconds your body responds
to breathing
if all that magic is going to happen
after a few seconds
what's going to happen if you breathe in
a healthier way after a few weeks or a
few months well we're seeing
these these people are able to overcome
these chronic illnesses they've had for
years and years
all right so if you were going to
instruct someone to breathe as poorly as
possible
what would you direct them to do i would
direct them to sit in front of zoom
all day uh hunched over and get stressed
out
about emails and then when they get up
uh they're gonna do their 30 minutes of
jogging a day right
so they're gonna put on their sneakers
they're going to go out and they're
going to breathe like this as they're
jogging
and then at night you know what they're
going to do they're going to go to bed
they're going to put their head on a
pillow and they're going to immediately
open their mouth and breathe through an
open mouth all night so what i'm the
portrait i'm painting here is obviously
the majority of the modern human
population
and we're breathing in ways that are so
dysfunctional that are causing so much
damage to our bodies on so many
different levels so
i mean i'm just being a little jokey
about this but it's
actually true there is even
you know a whole field of study looking
into something called email apnea
continuous partial attention syndrome
because people when they sit down and
get stressed out their breathing goes to
hell
okay and something like 80 percent of
office workers suffer from this so how's
that characterized
email apnea it's it's characterized by
you opening up your
email and you becoming so overwhelmed
and so stressed so immediately
and your threshold of stress is very
very low right
uh because we're not running away from
tigers anymore so everything
is stressful to us oh i'm watching the
bachelorette and she's not going with
this guy i'm totally
freaked out so i mean i i'm not
trying to be jokey i mean this is this
is what is happening to our
society so when you start your day off
that way what do you do what is the the
body's reaction
to fear you hold your breath
or you breathe too much
so our threshold for fear is so low that
we get a
nasty email from our boss what that
triggers is the same reaction that our
ancestors had
to hiding from a bear or hiding from a
saber-toothed tiger
we're doing the same thing and that's
fine to do for a short amount of time
that's why we're still around today
right to be able to respond this way
but to do that all day long is going to
trigger
this constant iv drip of stress and what
are
the vast majority of modern chronic
diseases tied to
stress and chronic inflammation almost
all of them
so breathing ties into this how you
breathe
influences your levels of inflammation
and stress we know that to be true
so interesting thinking about how
because
the biggest threats that we come up
against now are
down regulated we're in such a safe
environment that our bodies
can't tell the difference between a bad
email or an upcoming
awkward conversation with our spouse and
being chased down by something that was
life-threatening like anybody that's had
a really really nervous period at work
knows just how overwhelming that
sensation is like oh my god like is this
is my body even capable of creating this
much anxiety and concern
and then when you look back on it you
think god was even it feels like you're
in some sort of a trance
it feels like you're under hypnosis or
something
well i think it's you you nailed it
right there
is our worlds have become so controlled
the climate is controlled no matter
where we go the light is controlled no
matter where we go
and the more controlled and coddled you
get the less receptive you can be to
actual threats what's interesting is
we've moved
so far away from nature and actual
threats that when people are confronted
with situations in which they really
need to react like this
right in order to survive what do they
do
they completely shut down so so those
reactions that
enabled us to live in jungles and
savannahs for
millions of years are no longer
useful and they're a hindrance to our
health
and just like anyone can who's worked in
an office who's worked with nasty bosses
even good
bosses and co-workers there are times
when you are stressed where you can't
sleep right
you know i don't feel like eating you
know when
when you're in this state your blood
sugar goes up
your adrenaline goes up your cortisol
goes up you can't
rest and restore so this isn't
controversial
everyone knows this but what do we do
about it we
we resort to pills and powders some of
which can work really well
okay some supplements can work really
well but why not use something that you
carry
with you all day long and all night long
that will allow you to
immediately take control of that stress
and that's that's what breathing allows
you to do
i know this sounds like i'm over billing
this
but it get some instruments get a heart
rate variability monitor
and breathe in a certain pattern and see
what happens to your heart rate
variability
or your your blood sugar or your blood
pressure and more
what was the moment when you went from
being a
skeptic to a believer was there a
particular piece of
research that you came across or an
experience that you had where you went
okay there's there's really something to
this and it's now undeniable
i would not call myself uh a believer i
always want to remain a skeptic and i
still
am i mean after all journalists were
supposed to be skeptics i mean
that's what i back in the old days that
was your
job is to go in without any preconceived
notion of something
without any bias and it's so hard to
find that
and so as someone who is a journalist
and grew up in that world i want to
approach things and look at all sides
why wouldn't i talk to
everyone i could possibly find when i'm
researching a subject
yeah there's a lot of doctors and
researchers but there's also a lot of
clinicians and therapists who have
worked with people for 30 years and they
have something valuable to share as well
so you know i think this book took me so
long
because i did not believe what i was
finding
for so many years and this is true even
though this stuff was coming out of
harvard
and was coming out of stanford and i was
talking to these experts in the field
it took me years and years before i
convinced myself and then i had to
convince my publisher
my agent i said i think this is i think
this is
real and they said no no no for
another couple years until i finally had
enough scientific
studies and enough interviews and i gave
them audio files i said well
don't listen to me this is straight from
the person who studied this for 40 years
at one of the top
institutions this stuff is real and so
it was a progressive thing for me
i would understand and how mouth
breathing
was really that bad for you after doing
all of the research and
the science and some studies of my self
and then i would go on to the next thing
and finally it got to be so weird like
you can really heat your body up with
breathing
well there's the study done at harvard
you know if you don't believe me
look at the videotape from that study
tell us about that tell us about that
heating up study
so this was something that i kept on the
back
burner for a long time because i didn't
want to approach it because
it seemed so crazy whenever i told
anyone about this
including my people in my family who are
doctors they said this
is impossible so it's this
this process this breathing technique
called
tumo that has been practiced for at
least a thousand years in tibet
before that it was practiced by ancient
hindus
and what it is is using your breath and
using
meditation to heat up your body
and there are stories that date back
hundreds of years of travelers
going to india going to the himalayas
going to tibet
and seeing monks sit outside
at night in the winter time melting a
circle
around them so eight or nine hours with
just that very thin
sheet around just breathing melting a
circle nobody believed this
even when hippies were going to tibet in
the 60s they would come back and say
there's these people they do this so
herbert benson
at a researcher at harvard medical
school heard enough of these stories
where he thought maybe there was
something behind it or
he was going to bust this myth so he
went out to dharmsala
the way a good scientist does is goes
out there with equipment
with sensors sets up a study and found
out
these people could do all of this and
more and there's videotape
of the studies you can read the study
that was published in nature
which is the most highly esteemed
peer-reviewed journal
of scientific studies on the planet
and he showed that these people were
able to raise the temperature in their
extremities by 17 degrees they were able
to dry
a wet sheet placed over them in a cold
room
in about 40 minutes and again there's
there's video of this stuff so it just
shows you
when people actually show up when
researchers and scientists
scientists actually show up and do the
research
you can really discover some amazing
things unfortunately there's just not
that much
money to be made in these kinds of
studies there's there's no way to market
tumor heating
you can't market monks drying your
clothes by laying them on their back
you know uh maybe uh as a new washer
dryer situation someone can get a monk
and put them in the basement that might
be might be cheaper feed him some rice
there you go
but you know to uh wim hof has his
he's done such an amazing service to
people by taking these
obscure breathing techniques which he
did not invent and he is the first one
to tell anyone that
and to make them approachable to
everyday people
and so what he practices is a form of
tumor breathing which is why he can sit
in an ice bath for almost two hours
and not suffer from frostbite or
hypothermia it's supposed to be totally
impossible
there it is there's the study of him
doing that are those monks the same ones
that managed to heat
was it different hands or different
parts of the same hand or something
they're all using these are all
variations on the same theme so that was
swami rama who grew up in more of a
hindu tradition
but what i try to make clear in the book
is we name these breathing techniques
different names
they were different cultures claim them
as their own
but so many of them are all doing the
same thing and they're eliciting the
same effects when you look at
wim hof breathing and compare it to
sudarshan kriya and compared to other
vigorous pranayamas
they heal people in the same ways
because they're doing they're eliciting
the same reactions in the body
what is that reaction have you got any
idea what the mechanism is that's what
how what's happening with the breath
that causes the body to heat up or the
hand to heat up
well this is where to me it gets very
very interesting so if you take the wim
hof approach this very vigorous
breathing
some of your listeners i'm sure have
have done this breathing
this is a listening a very severe
sympathetic
nervous system response so it is
stressing
your body out you get a squirt of
adrenaline you get some cortisol
some epinephrine like that's why your
heart starts racing
you start sweating you feel tense in
short bursts of time this stress
called hermetic stress or hormesis is so
beneficial because just as we were
talking about earlier
how we just stay all day in the state of
chronic low-grade stress
this chronic state of inflammation these
short breathing techniques compound that
stress
so that you can chill out the rest of
the time that's why you're so relaxed
after doing that
so that's how whim is able to keep warm
what's interesting is that these monks
were able to decrease their metabolism
by 60 percent which
is way lower than someone in a coma
you should not be conscious and yet they
were able to
heat their bodies up with this reduced
metabolic state what the [ __ ] going on
there
wimph wim hof's method increases
metabolism
which is why he says he consumes twice
as much oxygen even
40 minutes after doing the wim hof
method
right so to answer your question what
the [ __ ] is going on with these monks
we still don't know which is what is so
awesome
about this after so many years of
testing these guys with every imaginable
sensor with every eeg looking at their
heart rates looking at their body
temperatures looking at their blood
pressures
we cannot understand how the human body
someone can take control of it to reduce
their metabolism
increase their heat and on that same
line swami rama right here's a guy
who on a single hand can
increase the temperature on one side of
his palm
while decreasing the temperature by 11
degrees
on his thumb so on the same hand
still don't know still don't know how
they do it
that's what makes my job interesting is
i get to fall into these worlds and
try to figure it out these guys are
freaks like this is insane
well i you know that's that's an
interesting
uh perception because i think
they view us as freaks for not having
this capacity
well we all have this capacity that's
what they're saying
they're like how dare you be born
a human with this capacity to do these
amazing things
and instead sit in front of your
computer and watch netflix all day
eating popcorn you know how dare you not
use your body to heat yourself up
to lose weight to control your heart
rate to control your blood pressure
so that's that's what i've learned and
i've heard the same thing from free
divers a lot of people call them freaks
these are these people who can hold
their breath for
six seven eight minutes at a time and
they can dive down to
300 or 400 feet on a single breath of
air i've seen it i'm a free diver myself
i've
experienced some of this we're born with
these mammalian dive reflexes that
trigger the deeper we get in the water
and you feel them coming on
and so people may look at freedivers as
freaks but free divers think of other
people as like
you're born with this everyone has this
ability
to dive and experience this true
spectrum
of of life and and what this body has
given us
and so few of us do anything about it so
i guess it depends on
what side of the uh argument you're on
but uh i
i guess i'm somewhere in the middle i i
don't want to spend 12 years in a cave
learning how to do this but i do want to
tune in to some of what my body is
able to naturally do for me yeah i guess
that
the perspective i have like them being a
freak is only
relative to the fact that i'm a normal
person to the freak the normal person
just looks like someone that isn't
maximizing their potential i suppose
yeah i mean talk to a buddhist monk
about
how we're living our so many of us are
living our lives in this extremely
materialistic world where
it's dog-eat-dog every single day and
but we don't have a larger context on
on what life is hey where did we come
from
where are we now where are we going when
when we die so
they view us as freaks and then we see
monks sitting around meditating all day
and
we view them as freaks so i don't think
the answer is to go
full bore into either of those sides you
can do that and that's great but we have
the luxury now in the modern age
to be able to dip our toes in different
things and see what works for us and
what's really sustainable
with that stuff it feels like cultural
conditioning masquerading as human
nature
you just have a particular group of
people and in that this is what's going
on
and you think well everyone does this
everyone thinks like this
that's just a scope insensitivity that
you've got going on there
well even closer to home think about how
people in the us and and in britain i
suspect
view this daily siesta we're like wait
what if you wake up work a couple of
hours in the morning
then you go home eat lunch for two or
three hours
and go to sleep and then come back for a
couple more hours
we view them as people in the
mediterranean
as complete freaks for doing this but we
know in matthew walker's book
when they've converted their lifestyles
to the typical
u.s or uk or north american
lifestyle their rates of cancer go way
up the rates of hypertension go way up
the rates of inflammation
the rates of of sickness are are off the
charts now
so maybe it's it's it's we who are the
freaks you know i don't want to get too
deeply into that but i really think it
depends
on context and even more importantly it
you can look at science and see what the
human body
really responds to what the brain
responds to what is the healthiest
and choose your path that way okay so
going back to our
poor test subject that you've given some
instructions to and is now
breathing in the worst way possible you
talk about them breathing too much why
is too much breath a bad thing
i would have thought more breath would
be good yeah and a lot of people thought
more food would be good
uh because more food equals more energy
so
what's very confusing when you get into
the biochemistry of breathing
and this took me months and months i
don't have a background in this stuff
which was a real hinderance it was a
pretty steep learning curve
is that you start to understand it's the
efficiency of breath
that is so much more important than the
volume so a lot of us think
we want more energy right we want more
oxygen we need more oxygen to get more
energy so i'm going to breathe more
that allows me to get more energy it's
completely
false so the opposite is true and we've
known this for more than 120 years
that when you breathe over breathe over
your metabolic needs
you offload too much carbon dioxide
without getting too
deeply into the weeds here what that
does is it inhibits
blood flow throughout your body and it
makes it harder for you
to get oxygen you can see this for
yourself
by over take 10 or 20 very deep breaths
and you'll feel some tingling in your
fingers and in your head
that's from a decrease of circulation
so in order to get the optimum amount of
oxygen you should be be breathing slowly
you should be breathing low you should
be breathing through your nose
by doing that you are pressurizing that
air and you're allowing that air more
time
in your lungs to travel down deeper
where that gas
exchange can happen so much more
efficiently you get
more oxygen with less work and less wear
and tear
on your body breathing this way and you
can see this by
feeling your heart rate when you breathe
in these slower breaths
and then if you have a pulse oximeter a
lot of people do nowadays
look at your blood oxygen levels if
anything they'll stay the same or often
go
up so this is just simple mathematics
and yet we've gotten this so wrong for
so long
and it's great that people are starting
to correct this and again we have
wearables that can show us and can prove
to us
how we're breathing how efficiently we
should be breathing in the future
what is some of the health effects of
poor breathing then if someone doesn't
fix the awful instructions you've given
well look look around look at the rates
of asthma look at the rates of panic
disorder look at the rates of sinusitis
of increased risk of allergies increased
risk of snoring
increased risk of sleep apnea diabetes
is tied to disorder breathing
as well i mean this list goes on and on
because if you're struggling
or if you're doing anything inadequately
all day long all night long guess what's
going to happen your body can keep
itself alive that's good but it can't
keep itself
healthy so it really starts
with stopping mouth breathing um
and this is the number one thing look at
nature look at any other animal in the
wild
look at how they're breathing right
they're breathing through their nose
look at an
infant breathing deep into the belly
into the nose
so this is the very first step and once
you condition yourself to be breathing
through your nose
you're a lot of the way there because
that breath through the nose
slows down slows things down it's hard
to hyperventilate when you're breathing
through your nose right
so that takes care of a lot of those
those rules and regulations
i got to tell you the story man so i had
a guy called stephen mcginty on the show
he's just written a book about
the pisces three submarine rescue which
is the lo
the deepest ever submarine rescue i
haven't in about 1970
and these guys roger malinson and roger
chapman were stuck
fifteen thousand feet down in a
submarine
for eighty six hours
on a bottle uh two bottles of oxygen
that were meant to last them
sixty so they
were talking through the breath cycles
that they needed to do they were
collecting the condensation from their
breath
on the surface to drink they had oxygen
tanks
so what they were doing and this was
really really interesting
they were purposefully alternating
between breathing through their nose
when they needed to make a decision and
breathing through their mouth
when they needed to conserve option
oxygen because the mouth breathing was
less efficient but that's actually what
they wanted
they didn't want to take as much oxygen
and they simply wanted to exist so they
tried to dial their breathing down to
about six breaths a minute
and breathe through their mouth and then
if they needed to do something
communicate with the surface run the
scrubber run the o2 tanks make a check
on
some sort of measurements then they'd
breathe through their nose for a little
while beforehand
the headache would abate a little bit
they would have a little bit more
cognitive function they'd do the thing
they go back to breathing through their
mouth quite slowly i thought that was
such an in-depth understanding of how
breath works and they stayed down there
on this
bottle of oxygen for a day and a half
longer than they should have done
crazy it's that that's a great story
um and we know that nasal breathing
uh affects how the brain works so
there have been numerous studies there
was one a couple years ago
out of northwestern university that was
fascinating looking at
rhythmic slow breathing through the nose
and how different areas of the brain
will come online
and different congregations of neurons
will start
lighting up in different areas to allow
communication
to work more fluidly between different
brain regions so the researchers said
that
actually breathing through the nose can
help you make better decisions because
it's changing the neurochemistry of your
brain
and the fact that these guys knew about
this in the 1970s is
really impressive because a lot of the
breathing research was coming out after
that time
and you know you don't have to tell them
the importance of nasal breathing
or or how the body responds to two
different
breaths i mean they experienced it
firsthand and what an incredible story
how does breathing fix the chronic
health conditions that you're talking
about so i understand
how it can cause things that are related
to sinuses and
airflow and stuff like that but i i less
understand like inflammation and
diabetes and things like that i would
have thought that would have
i don't know i don't understand how it
fixes it
so i want to be very clear breathing is
not going to fix
all of your problems right i'm not going
to offer anyone a blanket prescription
honestly
for anything no i'm not going to do that
and i'm not a doctor i'm not a breathing
therapist but what i have
found is that when people have very
dysfunctional breathing when you start
controlling your breathing and you
breathe in a more efficient way
the body can come back into balance i
can get into a few of these specifics
let's just talk about asthma okay
populations um with asthma tend to
breathe way too much they tend to
breathe through their mouth
they tend to have very low co2 so they
have low co2 because they are
constantly over breathing which is why a
lot of people with asthma
feel coldness in their fingers okay and
guess what happens
when you start over breathing and you
breathe more and more
you know that constriction i was talking
about in blood vessels
guess how asthma attacks start
you begin over breathing and that leads
to this downward spiral of more over
breathing can trigger an attack
the same exact thing happens with panic
so researchers did some incredible
studies several years ago
this was nih research very official
stuff
where they took groups of people with
asthma and panic
the only thing they had them do was
breathe more slowly
that's it okay and they were looking at
their co2 levels
and they said they wanted to get their
co2 levels up because when your co2
levels are up that's an indication that
you're breathing
in balance with your metabolic needs
just by having them breathe more slowly
these people were able to reverse their
asthma and
reverse their panic people were no
longer having panic attacks or asthma
attacks
you may think oh this is only one study
no there are
literally dozens and dozens of clinical
studies that have been done at hospitals
throughout the world just looking at
breathing
as an intervention for asthma and panic
so let's go to the other end of this
let's talk about
metabolism and breathing you're like how
the hell
could breathing be implicated in the
onset
of diabetes right this doesn't make
any sense but we know this is true when
you go
to bed at night and you have sleep apnea
or sleep disorder breathing
what are you doing all night long
when you're breathing this way you are
stressing your body out which is why
people with sleep apnea and other sleep
disorder breathing problems
have hypertension and it's also why
when you're stressing out your body
every one of those times that you're
holding your breath and stressing your
body out
your blood sugar goes up okay your
insulin goes up
after a while you get desensitized to
that
and after a while that can lead to adult
onset diabetes
and this is not my research this was
studied
30 40 years ago at stanford and
you can look at sleep apnea and diabetes
and find that there's it's even directly
connected with alzheimer's the onset of
alzheimer's because
sleep is our time to rebalance the body
and restore ourselves
matthew walker can tell you all about
this if sleep is the time when you're
stressing yourself out when you've been
stressed all day
your body is going to be destroyed and
that's what we're seeing right now
one of the things that i'm really
interested to try and dig into is how
much
people can influence their non-conscious
breathing with breathing exercises so
we can't spend every minute of every day
thinking about our breath or we've got
other stuff to do you know drive the car
or feed the kids or
answer the email or do the podcast is
there some sort of a spillover effect
that happens from focusing on your
breathing that then makes your
non-conscious breath pattern throughout
the day improved have you got any idea
of how this works
yeah so the point of this stuff isn't to
be walking around with a notepad
and wearing three different wearables
and to be a complete neurotic about this
i already did it for you folks it's not
fun i did it for years it did every
imaginable study just to get a
deeper view into this most of those
studies didn't even make it into the
book because i didn't want the book to
be about me i wanted to be about the
reader
the person who was breathing and reading
so
what i found is the point of these
things is to train yourself
to acclimate yourself to make
healthy breathing a habit okay
if you've been doing something
dysfunctionally breaking that habit can
take
weeks or months it can take a long time
but the key is to start very slow
and to gently go into this don't kick
your breaths
ass a lot of us in the west have this
approach where we just want to go
100 100 110 into something
save that for something else with
breathing you want to slowly acclimate
yourself
so that it feels natural so that your
body can slowly respond
to it and that's what these breathing
techniques
do and after a while you won't need to
remind yourself to breathe through your
nose because you will
always be breathing through your nose
including during exercise
okay i'm living proof of this and the
hundreds and hundreds of other people
who've written me
have found the same exact thing for some
people they're lucky enough after a
couple of weeks they're like cool i got
this i never breathe through my mouth
others take a few months
if you're talking about jogging or doing
zone 4
fitness this can take a lot longer than
that but we know that the performance
gains
of nasal breathing and recovery times
can be very profound so the simple
answer is
yeah the the point is to have
these things become a habit sometimes
that takes a while at
sleep it's harder because you're
unconscious which is why i like
some training wheels sleep tape nasal
strips nasal dilators can all help with
that
let's get into the sports performance
thing there'll be lots and lots of
people listening that are athletes and
want to try and maximize their
performance what did you learn about
breath's
impact on athletic output i learned that
athletes are more concerned with
efficiency than anyone especially
competitive athletes that's what it's
all about
who can run most efficiently so you can
beat your competitor right
we've got 11 pounds of muscles
operating our respiratory system and so
many athletes are focused on every other
muscle
i'm going to work on my wrists today and
now i'm going to work out my neck and my
ankles
you're not focusing on the muscles that
are delivering
energy to you when you're competing and
i think that this has been so
chronically overlooked for so long and
now people
are really clueing into it so
i will say that i've talked to some of
the real leaders in the field
brian mckenzie's a good friend patrick
mcewen's a good friend
these are people who have been training
elite athletes for
decades on the first thing they do
is they have them breathe correctly they
said before anything else that's what
they start with
so what they've found and there have
been numerous studies on this
is performance will improve after you
get over that
hump of becoming a nasal breather your
performance will go down
at the beginning and this is what a lot
of athletes don't want to see they don't
want to see their performance go down
but once you acclimate acclimate slowly
your performance
by and large and this is what they have
told me with hundreds and hundreds of
people that they've worked with
will improve and then your recovery
times will improve your vo2 max will
likely improve you can
likely build more blood too more red
blood cells
so you're able to do this because you're
breathing in line with your metabolic
needs
most of us when we're competing or
working out are breathing
too much that will trigger an excess of
lactic acid
which will make it harder for us to
recover it will also
trigger constriction in our blood
vessels right at the time when we really
need
oxygen if this is correct and it's more
efficient
for us to breathe slower
through our nose why does our body want
to do anything else
because our bodies are acclimated to
have a very
low threshold of co2 so what they're
finding now and there's been a lot of
research done on this in the past but
now
past and but now there's a lot more
interest in this so what they're finding
is that need to breathe is not dictated
by oxygen
okay it's dictated by co2 right now if
you
exhale and hold your breath you're going
to feel this nagging need to breathe
after a while
okay that's dictated by rising levels of
co2
and the more acclimated you get to being
comfortable with more co2 in your body
the more oxygen you can deliver to your
hungry cells
so whenever you feel that i really need
to breathe i really need to breathe
over breathing is not going to deliver
more oxygen to you
okay you want to breathe in line with
your metabolic needs
and that almost always is way slower
than you think it is
pulse oximeters can help do this breath
holding
exercises can really help get over that
that hump which is exactly why they're
using so many of these for
elite athletes but don't take my my word
for it talk to the athletes who have
converted to nasal breathing who have
adopted healthy breathing practices
and it's been a complete game changer
for these people
did you watch elliot kipchoge's breaking
two attempt
you see him sprinting towards the finish
line
and the guys i i don't i can't work out
if his mouth
is shut or not but it's not far off it's
definitely not wide open
and he just looks it's the same cadence
it's the same facial expression the
man's just
then i wouldn't be surprised if he's a
very very heavy nose breather
uh of course he is so i want to mention
one thing
especially for the people who really
like edging into that zone four
zone five level there is a time and a
place
for everything and this is what i've
learned from brian mckenzie who works
with elite
olympians so if you're about to dunk on
someone's head like it's okay to open
your mouth
take a huge breath if you look at
michael jordan right before he's dunking
he takes this
huge breath and dunks that's perfectly
fine
as long as you use that mouth breathing
as a tool
just like those people in that submarine
right they're using their mouth
breathing
as a tool a lot of people aren't
used to or even want to get to those
elite
states of athletic performance which is
why i don't mention this too often but
for those people who do
yeah resetting with some mouth breaths
if you've really reached your top
go back to nasal breathing totally fine
and if you look at sanya richards ross
who was the the top sprinter
for 10 years check out her
crossing the finish line and everyone
else behind her mouth breathing
mouth closed breathing through her nose
and kipchoge is
is the same thing it's okay to have your
mouth open a little maybe he's exhaling
a little because he's been running for
two freaking hours at 20 miles per hour
that's fine but the majority of his
breasts i
i guarantee are nasal dominant
and something that joggers can do if you
have a heart rate
monitor if you have a strap the straps
are the most accurate by far
check out your heart rate when you're
nasal breathing
versus mouth breathing and you will see
your heart rate
lower and if you're able to perform at
the same level of endurance
with a lower heart rate guess what
you're doing you're operating more
efficiently
and that means you then have more energy
to go a little
faster to go a little longer that's what
athletic
performance is is based on efficiency
and breathing
has to be a huge part of this brian
mckenzie was on the show a couple of
years ago and he said
he could tell an athlete's performance
simply by getting them to do a co2
tolerance test
he had a very good indication of what
this athlete was going to be like across
a number of different domains by just
getting them to
do one slow breath from the top okay
you've got as much time as you want
breathe in
fully breathe out start the clock as
soon as you stop breathing out i'm going
to stop the clock
that was it that's the only test that he
needs and on his uh state app
that's the regular retest that you do
right as you continue to work up through
it so yeah it's it's so crazy
here's something else so let's say there
might be a lot of people listening that
are maybe powerlifters crossfitters they
do sort of interval style work perhaps
other athletes how would you advise
someone to recover
in between sets because am i right in
thinking that we've got the
cadence i.e the speed of the breath and
then the depth of the breath are those
the two main
uh characteristics the two main sort of
parameters that we're playing with when
it comes to breathing
in between reps i think nasal breathing
is so important but i also want to be
very clear here
once you have acclimated truly converted
to nasal breathing
is where you're really going to see
these benefits at the beginning
some people may need surgery okay some
people do need surgery because their
nose are so messed up
but a lot of people just need
conditioning just like you need
conditioning with anything else
so there's two different things i i can
talk about
before you're conditioned nasal breathe
as much as you can
right it's gonna be uncomfortable but
don't
push it like try it for maybe half of
your breaths or a quarter of your
breaths
at the beginning then go back to your
mouth breathing that's fine
at the beginning that's what you've been
doing but then just
gently start increasing it as you go
along
it really helps to be nasal breathing at
night
this will help condition all those
tissues and different structures in your
nose
and will help more easily acclimate your
body to what you're doing in the daytime
also nasal breathing wearing a little
piece of tape while you're answering
emails or doing stupid stuff around the
house
can really help condition you to nasal
breathe so to answer your question in
between
reps is absolutely when you want the
heart rate to come down a little bit
you want your oxygen to go up and you
want to recover you don't want to be
stressing your body out i can't tell you
how many times i used to see this at the
gym
is people working out doing a few reps
and then just
it was like this macho thing to walk
around and go
like they're really working out the same
thing on a treadmill
on an elliptical there's people just
you're not doing yourself any favors if
you want to burn more fat you need more
oxygen
which means you need to be nasal
breathing more and breathing in line
with your metabolic needs
so it's just basic biochemistry but
again so few of us have
heard about this until recently that's
an interesting one so
even though nasal breathing will reduce
your heart rate
which most people would associate lower
heart rate less calorie burning
nasal breathing with lower heart rate
will actually increase calorie burning
your metabolic rate is going to be going
up from lifting weights and your
metabolic rate continues to go up after
you work out
right that's where you get the benefits
from the fat burning it's it's just not
always during your during the workout
it's
afterwards that that's the real benefit
of exercising
so if you're talking about burning fat
you need
oxygen to burn fat and you can
run anaerobically you can do that for a
while it's extremely
inefficient that's an inefficient way to
burn you're burning sugar that's cool
but you're also building lactic acid and
and causing
which is fine in small amounts but but
it can cause problems
later on so you want that combination
where you want to be working out into
your zone three zone four you want the
heart rate going up
but you also this is what heart rate
variability is you also want it to be
able to go
down your your and the benefits of that
fat burning
will be happening after as well if you
go on a three hour jog it will be
happening
during that as long as your fat adapted
and you're not just burning sugar as
long as your body can
easily switch over to burning fat
and you need oxygen to do that you also
need proper food to do that
one of the things i've just thought
there it feels
uncomfortable right the co2 tolerance is
your i tried to do it today
so i'm listening to the book earlier on
today and i'm going for a jog and i'm
not right james nestor's listening well
he's not listening but he's talking to
me so it's kind of the same thing
shut your mouth like breathe breathe
through your [ __ ] nose come on and
i'm
jogging along and you feel the
discomfort and it rises and it rises and
it rises and the
uh air thirst to want to breathe more
deeply through your mouth gets more and
more compulsive
i've got to guess based on how few
people i've ever seen
faint whilst running that that is almost
all psychological
and very far your physiological limit
for how much carbon dioxide you can
tolerate and how much oxygen you need
and how much more you need to breathe
through your mouth
is miles away from where your brain
thinks it is
a yes and no that depends on the person
people who
are very tolerant for high levels of of
co2 can push it too far
right but then you have free divers
who are almost inhuman in their
abilities
they've measured brain oxygen levels
of 50 percent in a in a free diver
so this is so far below what is supposed
to support consciousness but
and yet it does so i can't give you a
cut-off point what brian mckenzie does
and what patrick mcewen does is they
take you through interval training with
with breathing
right and that's what free divers do as
well when you're in a controlled
environment you're laying down on your
couch
and you're just holding your breath for
a minute at a time then you're holding
your breath for a minute and a half at a
time then you're breathing for 30
seconds and holding your breath
that's the best way to acclimate
yourself to co2
while jogging i do not recommend
especially turbo people who really like
to push it
to just hold your breath as long as you
can and say i'm not this is just
psychological
i don't want to be responsible for you
actually
passing out facebook yeah exactly what
you what you can do
are these this simple interval training
where
three seconds in six seconds out right
four seconds in eight seconds out and
maybe you do that
you start very lightly at the beginning
this is what i found really help with
with my surfing
and jogging even though i hate hate
jogging i try to do it anyway
even walking you can do this three
seconds in
10 seconds out it's gonna feel
uncomfortable
then after a few days or a few weeks
you're going to be like hey i'm
comfortable with this
i'm going to push it a little more this
is the responsible way of doing it
and you're going to notice something
that that i thought was fascinating
is you're going to feel all this heat
all this
warmth in like your fingertips in the
back of your neck
and this is circulation this is a
vasodilator that's what co2
is it's all of the circulation if your
body has that circulation it's able to
process
metabolites it's able to deliver oxygen
it's able to remove
other toxins you want that movement and
that circulation
and that's what this breathing allows
you to do so again
i would not suggest doing these epic
breath holds while you're working out
but work on the inhale and exhale ratios
and play around with that and do it on a
very softly and
in a mellow way at the beginning okay so
sleep
is snoring natural or not
no no no it's not it's not natural
at all and it neither is sleep apnea it
just so happens to be that so many
people do it we think it's normal just
like having
crooked teeth is not natural okay we
weren't intended to have crooked teeth
how many people have crooked
about 90 right so there are some breeds
of dogs that have been bred to have very
flat faces
guess what they have the same breathing
problems that that we have but
any other animal in the wild the vast
majority of animals
they're not going to snore and they're
not going to have sleep apnea and
according to the skeletal record our
ancestors very likely suffered from very
little snoring and sleep apnea as well
what causes snoring snoring is caused by
this soft tissue in the back of the
throat
vibrating right so it it can happen as
at back of the nasal pharynx as well
which is why some people breathe through
their nose they're like hey i'm still
snoring
because it can happen back there so
that's from this flabby tissue sleep
apnea is different that's a blockage
usually your tongue
it can happen that way it can also
happen in in other areas of the
oropharynx hypopharynx but
one of the leading reasons why so many
of us
suffer from snoring and sleep apnea
beyond weight which plays a huge role in
this
but one of the leading reasons why
people who are average weight
or underweight can suffer from these
things is our mouths
have shrunk over the last few hundred
years the human mouth has gotten
so small that our teeth no longer fit
and that's the main reason
why we're suffering from so many of
these chronic respiratory
issues weight lifters know all about
sleep apnea and snoring
because when you get too many muscles
around your
neck but your throat is not developed
properly to handle that inflow and
exhaling of air you can suffer from
sleep apnea which is one of the reasons
why so many weight lifters can suffer
from hypertension
is because they they suffer from sleep
problems
it's fascinating to think that snoring
isn't something that's natural it's like
a
it's like a rite of passage almost you
know it's such a cultural artifact that
everybody you have someone in a cartoon
and they're asleep the way that they
show that they're asleep is the fact
that they're snoring
yeah yeah i mean this is this is how bad
things have gotten
you know it's and once i started getting
deeply into this field so
a lot of us know by now sleep apnea is
such bad news
like have you ever had it i i don't
think i've got it i think i'd know if i
did
i only had it when i was in the stanford
experiment and i plugged my nose
i instantly got sleep apnea which is
really scary
it feels well you're unconscious right
so you don't feel it happening it's just
you wake up and you
you feel like you haven't slept a wink
uh your body's all messed
you're starving you're you have
anxiety you can't think straight it's
really bad and
20 of the population can tell you how
bad it is because that's
that's roughly the amount who suffers
from it but what people don't get
is that snoring and now the science is
really coming out about this
can have so many of the same problems as
sleep apnea
what happens when you're inhibiting
airflow in and out of your body you're
stressing yourself out all night
you have to struggle to breathe for
eight hours
out of the night you're not getting that
proper
deep sleep we know that and and
all of that rest and restoration that is
supposed to happen
in sleep takes a huge hit and i was just
talking to matthew walker about this and
he's like i totally agree
no one's talking about snoring they
think it's cute when you see an infant
snoring
this is someone who's struggling to get
energy
right and it's gonna completely wreck
them later on in life
all right so what are the top tips for
improving breathing during sleep
breathe through your nose easier said
than done right some people need surgery
okay some people can benefit from having
these mouth guards
those work as well but becoming a nasal
breather
only has benefit there are no side
effects is it going to cure all your
problems is it going to cure every
single person snoring to sleep apnea
no is it going to help you across the
board at some level
yes so why not do it i use a little
piece of sleep tape
i found that's beneficial other people
have used other props
whatever works putting the head of your
bed up about six inches
has been proved proven to be helpful for
some people
uh because it helps gravity when you're
putting your head down flat you're
working against gravity
your tongue is more apt to fall back in
in the back of your mouth so putting a
couple pillows
up and i'm a huge fan of this and it's
free
and again there's no negative side
effects i just got some books
and put the head of the bed up by six
inches it's called so they went under
the mattress
no no no uh under under the bed stand
you don't want to feel books when you're
when you're sleeping okay
all right so yeah the entire bed is now
at a little bit different it's cold
incline bed therapy check check it out
so the whole bed is at a slant now they
sell sleep number thing you can spend
ten grand it's been commercialized you
just need some books
you need some books or some bricks or
some wood or whatever the hell you have
sitting around
so i found that's helpful for people who
want to try to
figure out their snoring using their
natural body
sleeping on your back can really
exacerbate snoring and sleep apnea
you can tape a little ping-pong ball or
a sock
to the back of a t-shirt so that you
don't sleep on your back
they used to do this with people in the
military because you get much better
sleep when you're not snoring
so i can tell your your listeners may be
into doing this
and you can record what's working for
you with an
app i like an app called snorelab no
they aren't paying me to say that they
have a free version of it
otherwise it's like two bucks but this
records your sleep throughout the night
and you can wear whatever sleep tracker
you want and look at the quality of
your sleep and i've found that these
things can make an incredible difference
for some snoring and some sleep apnea
and again
they're basically free and uh there's
there's only benefits associated with
them
do you know how many people are going to
go to bed with a ping pong ball strapped
to their back their
mrs or their partner or whatever's gonna
say is that a
what have you got that don't worry about
this thing modern wisdom was on earlier
on
don't worry about it do you know how
many people go to bed strapping a
terrestrial scuba mask to their face
no so they don't suffer from sleep a
cpap machine
is that what it is how they manifest it
onto their face
do you know how many tens of millions of
people
are sleeping with a mask that pumps air
in and out of their bodies every night
because if they didn't have this their
sleep would be a complete disaster and
they die of hypertension
so a ping pong ball may seem here we go
with that
what's really weird who's the weirdo
ping-pong ball
may seem like a very stupid trick right
it's no stupider than living with sleep
apnea
or snoring which is causing a lot of
health problems
so and it's free wear a sock if
the sock get a cute sock and put that on
your back if that's if that's gonna help
you
um but these these things you don't have
to do these things you can wear a cpap
and cpaps work but
here are a few tricks you can try that
won't cost you anything
i hadn't ever heard of the vertical bed
incline thing before that's a really
really good idea
this is right up your alley and and now
there's there's some real science coming
out
check out incline bed therapy and
there's some guy who's been studying it
for 20 years he's
he's pretty wacky but he sleeps
vertically now he's managed to
work his tolerance to the point where
he's at 90 degrees he's gotten so good
yeah
now he sells straps and duct tape and
you can just tape yourself up every
night and there you go
glad you brought that up another new
market everybody check
amazon soon it will be man so
you talked about free divers and stuff
earlier on i know that you've got a
a recreational interest in it as well
what is some of the most
extreme feats with regards to breath
athlete what do you call them
uh not psychonauts what are they pulling
out
pulmonary that's it what are the most
extreme pulmonary
feats that you've seen that was an
umbrella term i made up because i didn't
know what to call
like what includes like a researcher a
scientist
a doctor but also a clinician and also
wim hof
like they all share the saying in common
where they're fascinated with the
science and
mechanics of breathing and so the
i mean whims pretty amazing and what i
love about whim
is that he's raised his hand and said
i'll do any scientific experiment at any
time
so he's putting his money where his
mouth is and what they're finding is
is things that are just completely
redefining our understanding of biology
by him volunteering to do this so he's
pretty impressive uh
you know free divers any free diver uh
impresses me and
what i love about free diving is you
think of the things that you can do on
this planet
where you won't be disturbed where there
are no text messages where there's no
emails where
no one can really where it's totally
silent and that's what the ocean is for
me and diving under the ocean so i've
found that free diving
you can do it as a competition people do
that that's great that's that's not my
jam i prefer it as sort of an underwater
meditation where you're just
using these these two air tanks called
your lungs
as your only tool to explore the ocean
and
animals respond to this they view you as
as one of their own because they go up
marine mammals go up to the surface
get a breath of air come back down they
see you doing it they get so excited so
it's really one of my favorite things to
do in the whole world is
is just to have that that silence and
that that moment where you're you're
truly immersed
in the ocean you're immersed in nature
but you're also
immediately connected to your own body
and its abilities
that's sick something that i've never
i've never done before but
i imagine that it must be a very
meditative experience
you've taken this breath you've worked
up you're somewhere as you say
silent surrounded by nature or perhaps
surrounded by nothing
must be really beautiful it is
and i think that freediving gets a bad
rap because people associate it with
competition
i've written pretty extensively about
the competitive side before i will not
go to another competition it just
and and again i don't want to anyone
wants to do that that's totally fine
you're free to do whatever you want to
do
but this other side of free diving
the meditative the the yogic side of it
and
you really understand and appreciate
breathing when you're doing this
as as well and you you can't do free
diving in an anxious state if you're
panicked
because you know what you can't hold
your breath in those states so you can
only do it when you are centered
into yourself and uh it's something i
have not been doing enough of because of
the pandemic and it's the first thing
i'm going to go out and do once things
really start opening up
it's interesting thinking about the way
that sports or a pursuit or a hobby
works as a forcing function for the
state that you want to get yourself into
so i had paul bloom on the show and he
was talking about
why people have uh desire to do extreme
sports
and it's a forcing function for presence
if you're base jumping in a wingsuit off
the side of a mountain
and you have a microsecond of lost
attention
you're dead so what it forces people to
do it
they may enjoy the actual pursuit itself
but what they also like is that the
requirements of the pursuit put them
into a state that they want to be in
it's like reverse engineering the act to
become
the the state right and it's the same as
what you're talking about here with the
free diving
the freediving can be great and
everything but you can't be stressed you
can't be
hyperventilating you can't be thinking
about these other things you have to be
in a state that you want to be in
and what you do is you use the practice
or the pursuit as a forcing function to
get yourself there
i think we have been evolved and our
biology
is as such that we really require these
states
and we've denied them for so long
whenever we go out and exercise now we
we're wearing four different sensors
we've got our phone on we've got our
headset on
and that's cool and i do that quite
often because it's easier to work out
that way
but those you think about when we were
hunting
food every single day right
when we evolved we were in these states
of extreme
quiet and focused where you weren't
thinking about
yesterday you weren't thinking about
tomorrow you were thinking about
that exact pinpoint
of a moment right there and i think that
our bodies
respond to this they respond to that
focus and it allows them to stay
balanced
afterwards i know that a lot of people
in wing suits or even free divers
they have a hard time living in the in
the terrestrial world
in the modern world without having this
release to reset
themselves which is why i find it so
interesting that
a lot of addicts some people with some
serious
drug issues have found free dive in and
said
this is this release this focus where
i'm able to just be
absolutely present on a moment
and instead of having being distracted
by everything else
naval ravikant has this quote where he
says we don't want peace of
mind we want peace from mind
and the breath work you know think about
when you do a wim hof session and you're
holding your breath your mind's not
anywhere you can't think about anything
it forces your
your your thoughts in that way the same
as the wingsuit the same as the
downhill mountain biking the same as the
jiu jitsu or the
the mixed martial arts fighting and the
same as other stuff that paul talks
about i think he's got a new book coming
out to do with the
the pleasures of pain um and he spoke to
a dominatrix that
said nothing catches the attention like
a whip and she was referring to the fact
that if you get slapped in the face
for a couple of seconds you don't think
about anything other than the fact that
you've been slapped in the face
peace from mind
it's interesting to think that we've
developed these different things
including meditation developed in
civilization
right so once we moved away from nature
hunter gatherers don't meditate
desperately
clamoring to get back there they're
we're finding different ways and
different tricks
to just suit what our bodies have been
thirsting for
for for so long and no matter how you
get that if you get that through
meditation or free diving or being in a
wing suit or even exercising and jogging
or surfing whatever that's great but i
don't think that we should
continue to undervalue those states of
some people call it doing nothing right
celebrating doing nothing
i consider that when you're in the
moment
being here now that's doing everything
that's that's where you need to be it's
just
our modern culture doesn't allow us to
to
lull around in that state for too long
and that's a crime
one year on from when you first released
the book is there something that you've
discovered since then that you wish that
you could have put in
so many things uh it's it's been
interesting and the
the real privilege is to now be in
conversations with so many
researchers not only the ones that are
in the book
who are all good friends now and will
remain good friends
so many other people i've been able i
did not think
that i'd be speaking at harvard medical
school and yale medical school in
stanford
uh but i have i've been lucky enough to
do that and
they've really sort of pricked up their
ears to some of the things i said was
and i told him i said give me a call
afterwards i'll show you the science and
now i'm
i'm working with some of these people
we're trying to boot up some studies and
you know so in particular there are so
many things and so for the
the us edition i'm gonna be slipping a
few of those those in but
this is uh an ongoing story um
i did the best i could with the time i
had to fit as much
as i could within this book but science
doesn't stop right
it is constantly moving forward and it's
so thrilling to see
some real active interest in academic
circles
into this stuff there already was for
for decades but there seems to be more
and i think a lot of that has to do with
covid
and looking at the importance of healthy
lungs and healthy breathing to help stem
off
some of the symptoms of long-term cobit
and that's exactly what we've been
finding
i think you're right as well with saying
that often it takes someone
who necessarily doesn't come from the
field you know you've said yourself
you're a journalist rather than
some hardcore breath scientist some
pulmonologist or whatever it's called
but popularizing science and being a
facilitator and a communicator of it
doesn't require someone to have the the
deepest knowledge it requires them to be
able to aggregate it and communicate it
in a way so
yeah i think if if that's something
you've been able to help those guys out
with then
quite rightly they should be coming to
you for for more and more
communication like this well it's you
know
and i'm not trying to be funny when i
say this is
i'm totally ignorant of these areas and
i was talking to joe rogan about this
when i was on the show
way back when and he's like i'm an idiot
and and i i am not embarrassed to ask
simple questions and these are usually
the questions that most people want to
ask but
but they're they're embarrassed to so
i'm not
embarrassed to say i know zero about a
subject before i go into it
i think it'd be very dishonest to sort
of claim otherwise
and a combination of that of this
ignorance in an area
but also curiosity when i work on a book
it's not an
eight hours a day thing it's it's all
day
all night i dream about it i write it i
get obsessed with it and
uh and i love that i love falling into
that
that world and honestly i miss it a
little bit so i'll be doing that again
soon going back in the office and
and digging in again but uh it you know
the long story is uh there's so much new
breathing research coming out
from so many top institutions and uh
it's about time is all all i can say
about that
beautiful man i'm really really glad
that you're the person that's decided to
put his
life and his nose and his time on the
line to make it work uh
the paperback edition of breath is now
available
everyone can go and get that from amazon
if they want to check out more of the
things that you do where should they go
so my website has i know i've mentioned
a lot of crazy studies that sound
impossible to believe
my publisher allowed me to publish the
entire bibliography on my website
because i knew a lot of people were
going to call bs on the stuff so you can
check it out at mr james nester
it's dot-com it's all for free there
i've also been doing interviews with
leaders in the field at harvard
and other leading institutions who can
talk about breathing in the intricacies
of breathing
i'm also trying to get better at this
instagram thing
so mr james nester is my handle and all
these new
studies and this new research i'm
finding i'm putting out on instagram
so that people can keep following up on
it if they want to get deeper into this
stuff
beautiful james thanks so much for today
all right thanks a lot for having me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace